holy [ __ ] it never changes someone has a
good idea they put the good idea on
paper and the good idea on paper becomes
a good TV show and then short-sighted
execs stamp it out before it can reach
its full intended epic fulcrum yep as
most of you know Joss Whedon's newest
show joins every other show he's ever
done in the island of misfit canceled
shows screw Fox
[Music]
I feel like foxes the mob and they're
gonna snuff me in the middle of the
night because I made this video I don't
care this needs to be said I'm a big fan
of Joss Whedon's he's one of those
storytelling geniuses in my book that
never really ever gets a fair shot
now dollhouse was not his masterpiece
that is always and forever will be
Firefly another Joss Whedon show that
was cancelled by Fox Firefly was superb
and it was canceled so it's not really
surprising to anyone the dollhouse was
canceled but it still blows personally I
think Joss did everything he could to
keep it on the air but when the studio
gods want to see you grab your ankles
it's gonna happen they just had to be
all like we all Fox Studios yeah we did
not can do don't have to sit what's not
we have stomped on Joss Whedon before we
shall do it again now how's our blood
pool movie going and so we will never
see the journey to the end of the world
in dollhouse how it was intended to be
seen simply do the corporate douchebags
I think the show is pretty much doomed
at the moment where you signed on with
the studio that canceled his last show I
mean come on you can't get back into bed
with someone who's already screwed you
over in that bad you already cancelled
one of my sweet-ass shows kind of way
when Fox aired Firefly they put it on
Friday night insuring shitty numbers and
inevitable cancellation and so 11
episodes aired out of order later
Firefly gets canceled and so Joss Whedon
creates his new brand child dollhouse
and what studio does it go to Fox who of
course airs dollhouse on Friday night
insuring shitty numbers and inevitable
cancellation a studio doesn't air a show
on Friday hoping for its success someone
could air on Friday the president
addressing to the world that America is
out of debt the economy is fixed there
are no more taxes ever we found the key
to eternal youth and every human being
on the face of the earth can choose
three superpowers to have as his or her
own and nobody would watch it simply
because a ton of Friday shows on Friday
are like old people in Florida they go
there to die Joss Whedon whatever you do
next don't ever work with Fox ever again
you would be better off having a show
that airs one day a year on the CW while
co-directing it with Eva Ball and to go
anywhere near Fox ever again just treat
Fox like it has airborne AIDS just stay
away if
else for RSA cuz we want to see the end
of one of your shows one day and Joss
Whedon isn't the only one who's gotten
screwed by Fox you guys ever watch
Arrested Development yeah I know
neither did I or anyone else because Fox
apparently hates the shows it airs and
it has a shitty marketing department
that was a good show that won Emmys and
Golden Globes and now it's cancelled Fox
canceled Family Guy at one point it's
back now but they cancelled it
someone should start a studio called the
what Fox throws away is actually awesome
so we're gonna pick it up and keep going
studio tuned in Fox makes me want to get
Twitter no I don't have a Twitter but I
would now just so all my tweets could be
anti Fox rages sharp yet subtle you know
like I just woke up and I still hate Fox
I'm at work thinking of Natalie Portman
and how I hate Fox [ __ ] Fox that would
be my entire tweet [ __ ] Fox alright
maybe not so subtle in the end Fox is
just a classic case of greed first
quality second it's got to be personal
Joss Whedon must have gotten a [ __ ]
from the Fox CEOs daughter during the
Buffy premiere it's the only thing I can
think of so this is just another
clear-cut case that the big guys
stomping out the little guy for the same
reason that dog licks its ball sack
because he can so if any of you out
there are gonna be CEOs executives or
the man in the future don't be douches
that's all I can ask just don't be
douches and keep an eye out for the
money saved on the dollhouse
cancellation to be put towards more
practical applications like another
subpar comic book movie screw Fox